we're taking calls at 6 1 7 830 4750
let's go to our next caller from the 737
area code caller what's your name where
are you calling from and you can jump
right into your question hi there this
just Mike calling from Los Angeles just
a quick question I'm actually on my
lunch break this will make it relatively
short sure have you ever could I'm sure
you've already talked about this
yesterday but as far as YouTube is
concerned do you to me you tues always
homie seen sing data center left in that
sense and as far as politically the
impact that YouTube has been is having
right now it is safe to say that's the
reason you and all the other assortment
of youtubers or progressives you believe
that's the for real what is the attack
so to speak you know if it is kill if it
is it's being hidden because right-wing
youtubers and left-wing youtubers are
both being hit now yes anecdotally I
went on Stephen Crowder's channel and
all his videos have ads that's a
right-wing channel and none of our
videos have ads and that's definitely
suspicious for now i'm attributing it
more or just just the entire YouTube ad
algorithm is completely screwed up right
now and I'm not jumping to this is a
partisan thing yet okay if I'm presented
with evidence that that's the case you
can believe that I will absolutely
retiree about it for right but right now
I've not seen evidence to suggest that
well okay cool yeah cuz I mean it to me
it seems obvious with everyone that's
been appointed it just seems one less
enemy with me tube you know I think it's
more if anybody if anybody's going to
order for if anybody's going to benefit
from the reduction of YouTube channels
making money it's just going to be
corporate media it's not going to be a
question of left or right although
corporate media by its very nature of
having this corporate structure tends to
be certainly center right at the least
but thanks so much i really appreciate
the call very important issue and you
can help us fight back against the
youtube advertiser boycott you can
pledge even if it's just
dollar a month you can do it at
patreon.com slash david pakman show patr
EO n.com slash david pakman show or
become a member at david pakman.com
slash membership